à dijon des zones d'ombré étudie au
troisième jour du procès en appel de
jean pierre murat accusé du meurtre en
1986 de christelle marie 16 ans dans une
cave au creusot il aurait avoué le crime
lors d'une soirée entre amis il ya plus
de 25 ans qu'il nie aujourd'hui les
témoins clés étaient appelés à la barre
compte-rendu pauline ringenbach
christophe gay il s'est mis debout et en
pleurant il a dit c'est moi qui tu es
christelle face à son vieil ami assis
dans le box à quelques mètres de lui
le témoin pen a prononcé ces phrases des
déclarations pourtant crucial dans cette
affaire les nombreuses hésitations de ce
témoin clé à la barre ont mis à mal les
nerfs des proches de la victime
aujourd'hui on a un témoin important
puisqu'elle est incapable de faire une
phrase correcte et les de dire ce qu'il
a entendu de répéter ce qu'il entend du
lot c'est énervant restreinte et moi
très important fallu sortir de la bouche
quoi donc
c'est énervant quoi ça fait 2 à prendre
avec lui et il faut lui tirer les vers
du nez
c'est assez énervant jean pierre murat
aurait donc avoué le meurtre de
christelle mairi c'était lors d'une
soirée arrosée en 1990 devant plusieurs
personnes
aujourd'hui l'accusé nie totalement
avoir fait ses déclarations il serait
possible qu'il ne s'en souviennent pas
et surtout il serait possible d'activer
déclaré ces propos en étant finalement
dans un état second consécutif à la
pathologie c'est la sienne
je trouve que les différentes
déclarations de jean pierre murat
montrent qu'il essaye de prévenir comme
un mauvais joueur d'échecs les coûts qui
vont venir mais qu'à chaque fois il se
ils se mélangent issa mélange
complètement et donc ça va dans le sens
de sa culpabilité ces témoignages
entendus plus de vingt ans après le
meurtre de christelle hnatow pas suffire
à prouver la culpabilité de jean pierre
mairat mais d'autres éléments troublants
comme son obsession pour cette affaire
ou encore sa passion pour les couteaux
viennent alimenter les soupçons et
retrouvez chaque jour la retranscription
des propos des différents témoins sur le
site internet de france 3 bourgogne